[Musique]
85 ans dans un autre centre a été créé
pour aider les gens souffrant de
troubles psychiques
je suis spécialiste du stress traniello
ged et soignent les patients qui ont des
problèmes de ce genre est en cours de ce
métal
nous sommes à séoul en corée du sud où
l'économie est florissante
tout le monde connaît les appareils
ménagers les ordinateurs et les produits
de beauté coréen si on regarde les
statistiques je dois admettre avec
regret que le taux de suicide dans notre
pays est très élevé une c'est vrai
quand on coupe une idée
la concurrence sociale féroce la
nécessité d'être toujours le premier
partout et le revers de la médaille
résultat le pays est classé premier pour
ce qui est de l'insatisfaction de la vie
[Musique]
nous sommes dans un véhicule de secours
dans l'un des quartiers de séoul
[Musique]
quelqu'un s'est senti mal au travail
les services de secours sont déjà sur
place et fournissent les premiers soins
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
secours parce qu'ils font face au stress
tous les jours ils ne voient pas que des
rapports ils sont des témoins directs de
la situation
ce jeune homme sauf des gens à chaque
shift je pense que la société coréenne
est marqué par une très grande
compétition tout le monde veut être le
premier
tout le monde essaie de faire son
maximum tout le monde essaie de
décrocher le diplôme d'une bonne
université
la course commence à l'école voir à
l'école maternelle
tout le monde veut une bonne école
maternelle pour entrer dans une
meilleure école après c'est le seul
moyen de passer les examens de
l'université de séoul par exemple mais
être diplômé d'une bonne université ne
suffit pas il faut aussi trouver un bon
travail
l'éducation ne suffit pas on en est
vraiment stressé il faut beaucoup
d'efforts pour trouver un bon travail ou
bien on en trouve un mais on n'est pas
assez performant et on est obligé de
partir je pense que tout ça est excessif
il ya un autre problème
notre culture nous oblige à sauver les
apparences en corée les gens sont très
stressés si l'on a une mauvaise opinion
de à la maison tout comme au travail
nous avons demandé au secouriste de nous
raconter s'il a souvent affaire à des
suicides
comme je vous l'aï dit je travaille dans
un quartier de séoul où nous avons
beaucoup de tentatives de suicide
surtout parmi les femmes qui travaillent
imaginons qu elles ont emprunté de
l'argent et qu'elles ne peuvent pas
payer ils prenaient leurs dettes que ça
devienne une source constante de stress
qu'elles ne savent pas s'en sortir
une seconde une seconde s'il vous plaît
l'attaché de presse des secouristes
intervient dans la conversation
vous vouliez poser des questions sur la
société coréenne c'est bien ça vous
savez dans notre société les gens
travaillent beaucoup
leur travail est source de satisfaction
et de stress surtout à présent la
conversation tourne autour du sujet du
suicide c'est bien ça on voulait
connaître le rapport entre le suicide et
le stress
c'est ce qu'on appelle encore et perdre
la face
donc je dis trop de choses négatives
auxquelles je ne parlerai que du positif
vous savez c'est cette attitude qui a
permis à la corée d'atteindre son niveau
actuel
[Musique]
ans
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parc appartient à la jeune génération il
ne s'est pas tourné vers une carrière
dans une grande entreprise il est
producteur de sa propre émission en
streaming mais la vie de parc n'est pas
dénué de stress
bernard bonjour magic creator park tae
ho magic creator excusez moi désolé
aller désolé oui donc bonjour partagé au
magic creator je suis responsable de
beauté de produits de beauté pour hommes
de chirurgie esthétique de ce genre de
truc mais j'y arrive pas
[Musique]
park nous a montré l'un des moyens les
plus populaires et simple de lutter
contre le stress en corée
nous avons goûté un prêt spécifique le
knb jim je me prépare à lancer une
nouvelle émission
donc j'ai eu beaucoup de rendez vous
dernièrement et je suis tout en sous
stress j'ai donc décidé de dîner épicé
ce soir avec mes amis et protecteurs
beaucoup de jeunes mangent de la
nourriture épicée pour évacuer le stress
la nourriture épicée contient des
endorphines qui ponctuent katako tout le
monde sait que cela remonte le moral
entier les études réalisées sur des
animaux montrent qu'un repas épicé est
source de bonne humeur
parmi les paramètres
[Musique]
on
kim yong et le président du syndicat des
employés de l'hôtel de ville et ils
parlent ouvertement des problèmes liés
au stress au travail
ces dernières années il ya eu 3 tourne
en trois épisodes qui ont marqué séoul
d'abord de suicide en 2015 un nouveau et
un fonctionnaire expérimenté depuis en
un autre fonctionnaire de la mairie
s'est suicidé chez ces événements ont
choqués et ont engendré des changements
dans la culture de bureau le chef du
syndicat est venu soutenir le
rassemblement pour les droits des femmes
qui ont été licenciés les manifestants
portent des vêtements de deuil car la
perte d'un emploi en corée du sud est
synonyme de mort
[Musique]
malheureusement les femmes sont
discriminées au travail et
c'est le cas dans de nombreuses
entreprises coréennes y compris dans
celles j'ai travaillé la majorité des
employés étaient des femmes et elles ont
été toutes licenciées
nous portons donc des vêtements de deuil
les mêmes que nous mettons pour les
faits n'auraient dans nos parents en
signe de protestation
[Musique]
pour les coréens
le travail est une question de vie ou de
mort voici les chauffeurs de taxi de
séoul qui protestent contre humeur
l'histoire est banale über arrive sur un
marché mature les prix baissent les gens
perdent leur emploi ces conducteurs se
sont suicidés après avoir perdu leur
travail
il causait de travailleurs se sont
suicidés en 2015 à trois jours
d'intervalle un ancien l'a fait sur son
lieu de travail
comptez le second était un nouveau il
n'a pas supporté la pression venant de
son chef
un autre travailleur s'est suicidé en
la police a examiné les images filmées
par la cctv
il est monté je crois au 13e étage de
son immeuble
je ne me souviens pas exactement et il a
sauté un suicide semblable a eu lieu
trois jours plus tard le 28 décembre
[Musique]
les suicides provoqués par le stress au
travail ne sont qu'une partie du
problème
nous nous rendons auprès d'un groupe de
soutien pour les femmes dont les maris
sont morts de surmenage
elles ont préféré rester anonyme pour ne
pas avoir de problème quant à
l'obtention de compensation de la part
des entreprises pour lesquelles leur
mari travaillait
[Musique]
ici j'ai dessiné mon mari cela ne veut
pas dire qu'il buvait et fumait beaucoup
de cette année cela montre que même
s'ils vivaient en société il était
toujours seul match il m'a dit je vais
dire qu'il était tout seul face à ses
problèmes
si comme le prétend m c'est la chose la
plus importante dont je me souviens ça a
été une moitié de vie mais on dirait qu
il préférait aller boire ou fumer
plutôt que de me parler de ses soucis et
d'essayer de sourire à quai l'alcool est
l'un des moyens les plus populaires
d'évacuer le stress célébrer la fin de
semaine de travail avec ses collègues
est presque devenue une tradition en
corée du sud
ishiguro et on peut se dire que boire et
relaxant glace est très commun c'est
comme la consommation de plats épicés et
shutter les gens tu penses tu évacue le
stress mais la consommation prolongée
d'alcool et musique en mer conjuguer la
nourriture épicée
c'est comme en algérie
[Musique]
ces dernières années les soirées du
vendredi soir ne sont plus aussi
fréquentes dans la culture d'entreprise
[Musique]
j'ai froissé cette feuille de papier
pour mettre en avant les désagréables
condition physique du corps je pense que
c'est à cela que ressemble lien entre le
corps et l'âme des personnes qui
travaillent de nos jours
beaucoup d'entreprises réduisent
aujourd'hui le temps de travail
l'administration insiste pour que les
employés rentrer chez eux afin de se
reposer
ils peuvent même atteindre l'électricité
une fois la journée de travail terminée
afin que les gens ne puissent plus
travailler mais là encore ces mesures ne
sont pas une vraie solution car les gens
travaillent alors de chez eux
le dilemme des employés est évident le
nombre d'heures est réduit mais le
volume de travail restent le plus
souvent identiques
[Musique]
j'ai essayé de mener une vie comme il se
doit j'espère que vous aurez une vie
plus heureuse et qu'on se reverra dans
un lieu plus heureux nous avons eu des
temps difficiles les drames familiaux me
faisait mal ne vous blâmez pas je vous
ai pardonné
pardonnez moi s'il vous plaît si je vous
ai offensés je vous aime tous
[Musique]
l'expérience de la mort est un programme
d'état
ma mère mon père mes émois bienvenue à
tout le monde est là 900 36e session de
l'expérience de la mort enchantée de
vous rencontrer
[Applaudissements]
ce centre a été créé pour deux raisons
importantes
la société sud-coréenne prospère sur le
plan économique traverse une crise de
valeurs et la corée du sud fait ce
qu'elle peut pour la surmonter
hong kong les gens devraient comprendre
qu'il ya des choses importantes qu'on ne
peut ignorer les relations familiales ou
avec soi même et donc votre 30
il faut le comprendre avant de mourir
nous donnons de l'espoir et des forces
aux gens qui pensent sérieusement au
suicide
le centre s'est fixé un objectif
beaucoup plus ambitieux que la seule
lutte contre le stress
les visiteurs sont invités à réfléchir à
quelque chose de simple la vie n'est pas
sans fin et cette dernière peut arriver
plus tôt qu'il n'y paraît
ty télé beaucoup de gens croient qu'ils
vivront très longtemps ils remettent
souvent à plus tard des choses
auxquelles il aurait dû prêter attention
avant relations familiales ce qu'ils
aiment quand on fait en sorte que la
personne comprenne la réalité et
l'imminence de la mort elle commence à
se tourner vers ce qui est vraiment
important et qu'elle a eu l'habitude de
négliger leur tanière après une petite
présentation
les visiteurs vont dans la salle de
funérailles c'est une énorme salle où se
trouvent des dizaines de cercueils
[Musique]
les participants prennent place à côté
de leurs cercueils ils revêtent détenus
d'enterrement pose une photo et écrivent
une lettre d'adieu
[Musique]
et tu dis ma chérie qui avoue si je
meurs nous pardonne moi ces mots bientôt
je te demande de ne pas te re marié
continue de vivre avec nos enfants comme
tu l'a toujours fait quand j'étais là
[Musique]
l'heure des funérailles approche tout le
monde s'allongent dans les cercueils qui
sont ensuite refermée les visiteurs
doivent passer un certain temps à être
mort
[Musique]
le point culminant de la cérémonie est
la renaissance chacun sort de son
cercueil avec une nouvelle perception de
la vie et de la mort
où donc je n'ai que j'entends encore un
cocu ça fait sans doute que d'après les
statistiques les gens se suicident
majoritairement à 20 ans j'ai pensé que
ce serait bien que les jeunes sur le
point de se suicider et on vient ici
voir ce qu'est la mort venir pour
comprendre l'importance de ce qu'ils ont
dans la vie d'être si vous ne serez
point extrême et donc quand on va au
bout
claude homawoo d'union
la corée du sud contemporaine est le
résultat d'une société hautement
compétitive on pourrait dire que le
stress est un effet secondaire négatif
mais cela a aussi un impact positif dans
une société hautement compétitive
on doit toujours aspiré à être une
meilleure version de soi même
[Musique]
park se rend dans un temple où il va
faire une pause loin de la vie
trépidante de la ville le chemin vers
soi est un autre moyen populaire
d'évacuer le stress est de définir
clairement ses priorités
voilà ce que park recherche
[Musique]
tout le monde peut venir ici et de venir
novice dans un temple ne serait ce que
pour un moment il s'agit de vivre comme
les autres habitants du monastère
s'habiller comme un novice dormir comme
un novice manger comme un novice
changer radicalement son mode de vie
[Musique]
un poster sur les enfants voici le temps
plein air j'espère qu'ici je pourrais me
libérer du stress accumulé au travail
l'objet de la haine de la colère qui
déborde en moi c'est la turquie des rois
sont là allez on va voir comment c'est
[Musique]
le séjour en temple est une pratique
populaire
ceux qui viennent ici sont confrontés à
différents problèmes les uns essaie
d'accomplir un deuil
d'autres cherchent à se détendre après
le travail certains tentent de dompter
leur agressivité ou ont des problèmes
d'alcool
[Musique]
ils sont là en pleine cérémonie
d'inclination il doit faire 80
inclination un véritable défi pour un
citadin
[Musique]
d'abord ça a été difficile
c'est dur de s'incliner d'accord mais
ensuite c'est comme si j'avais eu un
second souffle s'est soudain devenu plus
facile
j'ai même senti les ondes négatives me
quitter quant à lui je suis fatigué
dragonica
mais en même temps je me sens l'esprit
léger
c'est une pratique qui procure un
confort spirituel ça a été je ne suis
pas religieux mais quand je suis venu
ici dans ce temple bouddhiste et que
j'ai vu les moines
je me suis tout de suite senti en paix
en effet la méditation réduit le stress
et améliore la concentration la
méditation est particulièrement utile si
vous êtes en trois ans un stress
générale provoquée par ce qui vous
entoure
il ya même des courts qui permettent de
maîtriser les bonnes techniques sur tous
les coups on y va pour le travail je
cherche toujours des moyens pour
développer mes compétences
j'aimerais beaucoup apprendre de
nouvelles choses tout le temps qu'il m'a
dit je veux surtout savoir si j'ai
choisi la bonne voie
le bon chemin et oui c'est vrai j'y
pense tout le temps à autre et savoir si
ma voie professionnelle est la bonne
cela vous préoccupe aussi je suppose que
j'ai des problèmes similaires
je suis un peu plus âgé que de trois ans
j'ai 32 ans
c'est à peu près à ces tâches qu'on
commence à réfléchir au sens de la vie
c'est important pour moi
les coréens pense beaucoup à leur
carrière tout le monde essaie de trouver
la route vers le succès et s'épuise en
la cherchant
ce couple a créé une entreprise après
avoir traversé un burn out from ça il ya
une vingtaine d'années j'étais comme
procureur c'était une période difficile
je travaillais beaucoup et j'étais sous
stress permanent
quant à cause de ma situation
personnelle je ne pouvais pas quitter
mon travail ça se soutenir
je buvais et je fumais énormément
c'était ça mon mode de vie
[Musique]
mais là je me suis dit mon dieu mener
une telle vie va me tuer comment puis-je
faire pour m'en sortir
b le travail de coin était d'envoyer des
gens en prison après avoir pris sa
retraite il a décidé de s'envoyer en
prison lui même est de créer une
entreprise par la même occasion
ici est écrit la prison qui est en moi
[Applaudissements]
les propriétaires de cette prison sont
ces principes aux prisonniers le couple
à ces cellules préféré s'est vu préférer
qu'il préfère purger leur peine à l'
isolement
[Musique]
la nourriture est servie à travers une
trappe dans la porte
l'espace est tout ce qu'il ya dans cette
chambre est suffisant pour passer du
temps avec soi même source
[Musique]
grâce à la prison ses fondateurs ont
retrouvé leur liberté
passer du temps avec soi même et le type
de traitement anti stress offert ici
[Musique]
closer nous offrons la possibilité de
réfléchir à sa vie mais ce n'est pas
obligatoire
on apprend à être seul avec soi-même à
remettre ses idées en ordre
ici les téléphones portables ordinateurs
moyens de communication modernes sont
interdits cependant vous pouvez utiliser
un stylo et un cahier beaucoup de gens
commencent à écrire ou à dessiner en
purgeant leur peine
[Musique]
vraiment les gens écrivent très bien ils
écrivent avec leur âme
certains sont tellement inspiré par ce
qu'on écrit les autres ou ce qu'ils ont
écrit eux mêmes qu'ils continuent
d'écrire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le bon ma peau est un bon exemple
montrant comment la corée du sud fait
face au stress avant 2013 ce pont était
un lieu d'où l'on se suicider beaucoup
de psychologues et de designers ont fait
de leur mieux pour faire du fonds un
espace sur les phrases qui sont écrites
le long de la rampe sont censés réduire
le niveau de stress chez les personnes
désespérées ces phrases nouer un
dialogue entre le pont et le passant en
plus d'être sous vidéo surveillance
permanente
le pont a aussi un poste d'appels
d'urgence grâce à tout cela le pont ma
peau qui avait si mauvaise réputation a
changé de nom maintenant on l'appelle le
pompe de la vie après tout la vie est
toujours plus forte que les statistiques
lugubre
[Musique]